everything is set for the big launch
don't drop it
always shall fear fight balls on there
I've set up burners so my team can
finish up the soup and pan fry the
scallops in front of the guests mistakes
won't be easy to hide every year in this
chair at the moment we have four
thousand four hundred people coming in
in and out of ok and the current no
sooner has governor ed Tillett started
his welcome speech test fur is burning
things is the key actually to reducing
reoffending
but other things are important as well
but the most important thing is getting
a job the last thing I want now is more
cock-ups nice watch the sides but Andrew
Inslee has got his portion sizes all
wrong
you run out of soup cheese half the
[ __ ] table sir I said two thirds full
they're guys guys look at me in front of
these guys come on
unbelievable Inslee and Kelly were to
serve David her Sam's leftovers I'm
hoping these potential commercial
partners haven't spotted the mistake
it's absolutely delicious next the main
course the beef Wellington's have to be
perfectly cooked
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's not very easy dish to to get right
out there me to be perfectly sir them
because come out really well lunch has
been a success now it's finally time for
the real purpose of today's event the
unveiling of the slice we launched this
today a treacle bar made behind bars by
a bad boy bakery you're having a little
sample today if there's one message I
could ask you all when leaving this
prison is to get the word out get used
to this because you can see a lot of it
and with your support insights and help
we can really take this to great heights
and I think these guys did an amazing
job these capes are now's my chance to
drum up interest in a commercial deal
the people I want to target movers and
shakers in the coffee shop sector
I think that's why perky throughout and
boy this is different and people might
actually be more interested to purchase
it when there's a story behind their
product but is there something there
that contain more closely on Richardson
is a consultant to some of the UK's
best-known coffee chains and a major
player in industry sometimes something a
fraction Leslie a always job things a
slice recipe needs tweaking to get it
into the high street coffee shops we
could make that less sweet yeah I'm sure
more base that's triple yeah we have an
amazing team there yeah phenomenal
production kitchen right cheap labor
costs yes and we can produce a high
volume yeah no one's going anywhere
they're not in a rush to go home yes
excellency
that's very positive
I mean potentials there he's interested
in having a meeting and developing
something less sweet so they can be it's
a great start
today has also been my opportunity to
get the Prison Service top brass behind
the slice you can't fail to be impressed
by what's happening here today it's
absolutely fantastic it will leave the
legacy that's what we're after and I'll
enable us to make it a success not just
for today but for the future the VIP
guests are leaving with a positive
experience of the bad boys bakery I'm
happy I've gotten the Prison Service on
site a great product and interest from a
potentially major commercial partner
now you know in order to protect the
future of that boy bakery that slice has
to go nationwide I've got to roll that
out that's the most important thing now